roll tape Shawn
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding hello everybody welcome to a
special episode of the minimalists
podcast
my name is Joshua fields Millburn and
what you're about to hear is a
conversation between Ryan and me about
criticism we have people ask us about
how do we deal with criticism and ask us
this all the time and what I can really
tell you is that the more you do the
more good you do the more you create the
more you put yourself out there the more
you're gonna get criticized and so it's
really important to develop these
calluses that help you deal with that
criticism we recorded this episode
shortly after our podcast on debt aired
which was podcast number 28 and we got a
lot of criticism on that and so we want
to sit down and have a conversation but
we didn't want it to just be a
conversation about that podcast in that
criticism we didn't want it to be a
rebuttal to that and so we sat on this
episode for a while so that we could
deal with criticism as a whole and get
this into our feed for you
speaking of criticism we we've produced
something new for you to criticize if
you enjoyed our first TEDx talk we think
you'll enjoy our new TEDx talk which is
called the art of letting go you can
find that over at the minimalists com or
on our youtube channel which is
youtube.com slash the minimalists we
recorded this out at TEDx Fargo last
month and it was sort of the obverse of
our first talk which was called a rich
life with less stuff and so the first
talk was a lot of Ryan talking and me
doing some sort of theatrics and this is
the opposite of that where I talked that
did much of the talking but Ryan
performed a lot of the the theatrics
behind it and we talked about minimalism
and really the benefits behind being
willing to let go of material things of
status of identity of sentimental items
just the
the art of letting go we hope you enjoy
that feel free to criticize it as much
as you like also speaking of criticism
thank you for all the kind words and
feedback and and otherwise on our
documentary which is called minimalism a
documentary about the important things
people have seen that documentary in
more than a hundred countries right now
and you can watch it right now if you
haven't already over at minimalism
film.com that has more than 6 hours of
bonus interviews there also it will soon
be available on iTunes and on Amazon
we've heard you loud and clear we know
you want to see it on other platforms
other than Vimeo you can pre-order it
right now on iTunes and Amazon just type
in minimalism documentary that's all for
now I hope you enjoy this conversation
that Ryan and I had about criticism and
I think we're live well we're not
actually live we're taped alive
we're live to tape yeah live to tape
we'll go with that but actually that's
not even true because Sean can edit this
right oh yeah welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less I'm
Joshua fields Milburn and wait and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus I thought maybe I got my
name wrong for a second for some reason
I thought there was more than
introduction it's weird when I don't
have like the sheep in front of you yeah
we're off script today we were styling
today Ryan we were sitting down the day
and and he and I were having a text
conversation yesterday and I figured we
just pulled us into the podcast and our
last episode was about debt and it's one
of our most popular ones in terms of
great listener feedback and and just
great responses and people saying thank
you so much but then there's this other
side as well it's so it's so Ryan I'll
tell you this it saddens me that that
debt has such a controversial topic yeah
I was pretty shocked like the people who
were just defending how great debt can
be like like it saddens me how much
people believe in debt I guess is what I
think
we've been sold this meme for so long
that you're supposed to be in debt and
and people don't like it to hear the
absolutes like when I say there's no
such thing as good debt and and they'll
give examples of you know this heart
surgery I had to have or that's a of
course like I say that can be a tool and
it can be justified and and so I want
people to keep in mind when we're giving
out when we're talking about these
things this is what works well for us
and we're not being prescriptive about
it if you want to go out and get all
that good debt that you want I feel bad
for you because I associate that with
not having enough freedom yeah well and
I'll be honest with you Josh
if we've got a listener out there who
can send me the million dollar portfolio
on how they amassed a bunch of wealth
from incurring massive amounts of debt
I'm open to changing my mind that and
how you can do that regularly I mean
right I think Donald Trump is the poster
child of this and what we won't get into
politics and not that you and I would
necessarily agree with Donald Trump on
just about anything but but the truth is
he is the master of leveraging debt to
to at least be Alston Sulli wealthy and
and it's debatable as to whether or not
he's worth 150 million dollars or 10
billion dollars or somewhere in between
depending on the estimates but he's he
is the debt leverage er and and that's
certainly what he does but I think for
the layperson what we need to do is we
need to step back and say is this debt
justifiable is getting a new car and and
having a 5-6 year essentially a mortgage
on your car is is that justifiable and
for me the answer is always going to be
no and and and then of course we somehow
pissed people off with the whole the
credit score discussion yeah when people
get frustrated because yeah III will
tell you that having a credit score is
really having a debt score and a lot of
people say you don't understand I have
to have a credit score because of X Y or
Z and and you know what if you really
feel that you need to improve your
credit score great I'm going to
courage you not to get into debt to
improve your credit score keep that in
mind your credit score is the only way
to really build a credit score is to
have reoccurring that now you can game
the system and you can pay it off
regularly and still maintain a credit
score I'm not telling you that having a
credit score is a bad right right of
course not what I'm saying is it's not a
necessary thing for us either even if
you go out to purchase a house it you
can you can get a mortgage that does not
require you'd have a credit score they
require you to have a proof of income
and by the way they're gonna require
that anyway you can you can't go to them
say you know I don't make any money but
I have an 800 FICO score can you give me
a $300,000 loan for a house
no can you prove you can pay for it no
but my credit is outstanding
okay and so Ryan I I didn't want to talk
today really about about that I mean
here's the thing realize that that any
of the the suppose advice that we give
out it's not an advice for you
specifically this is a recipe that Ryan
and I are sharing from our own lives and
what we'd love for you to do is tweeze
out ingredients and and hope that they
are you're able to create your own
recipe to to apply those ingredients to
your life so that you can figure out the
path that's right for you and the path
that's right for me is a debt free path
and we give we give these tips because
we care about people and we don't want
you to have to live under that anchor
that weight of all this debt and believe
me I know about it and six figures worth
of debt close to half a million dollars
if you count my mortgage in debt and and
getting free from that is it opens up
all these possibilities I'm no longer
tied to a particular lifestyle I'm not
tied to an income you don't have to be
tied to a geography you're not tied to
to anything financial and that's
beautiful because then everything you do
becomes deliberate whereas before Ryan
you and I are working in this this
corporate career and we became tied that
lifestyle hmm and I had to make you know
at least a hundred thousand dollars a
year in order to to just pay my bills
basically to keep up on your debt you
yeah keep open money to keep your debt
payments right if they keep up with the
Joneses cuz the Joneses had similar debt
to me I mean you remember the
neighborhood I used to live in every
house looked identical it was it was
Stepford almost and the suburban house
with with more toilets than people in a
full basement just just full of stuff
that I wasn't using but I was paying for
I was paying for the space to store it
I had a storage locker on top of that
for a brief period of time because well
I had already or fully organized my
basement full of stuff and I had to pay
it for that and now I'm paying to take
care of the other stuff I'm not using
and so I don't want you to be crippled
by debt I don't want you to be confined
by your debt and so if you can get out
of debt that's really all it is and
today I really wanted to move into
something I really want to talk about
criticism because we got just a ton I
was shocked by the amount of criticism
and people wrote articles about about it
and thankfully I didn't catch that they
wrote articles about the party Ryan does
a better job of ignoring the criticism
yeah I'm just blocking this out
altogether I just don't care anymore
yeah and that's what that's exhort I
would have leg read everybody criticism
and been defended myself as much as I
could yeah sure
and I I dipped my toe in the stream this
time around and and responded to some
people on on Twitter and again I want to
point this out probably most of the time
is 99% of the feedback that we get is
outstanding and then the other 1% is
just glaring you know hate and people
people throwing Rotten Tomatoes at us
yeah I'm just thinking feces but Rotten
Tomatoes as well I just feel like
sometimes it's like Union when you go to
the zoo and you see like a chimpanzees
just like throwing feces at a wall
that's that's what it feels like
sometimes and so I want to talk about
good criticism and bad criticism today
because it's not like we're not allergic
to it but I think most of it is is bad
so let's start with with the bad side of
things in the corporate world we used to
talk about these the seagulls and so we
have an essay from from our book
essential and I just wanted to read a
quick
excerpt from that this essay is called
seagulls criticism is inevitable unless
you do nothing important with your life
but whenever you put yourself out there
whenever you expose your ideas to the
world be it via social media blogs or
business meetings you're effectively
wearing a sign that says criticize me of
course some criticism is beneficial
feedback from people respect helps us
grow other criticism however is toxic
the most virulent example is the cynical
internet troll so we're kind of talking
about that today I think trolls are like
seagulls they fly in [ __ ] all over you
and fly away and they're not informed
enough to understand the implications of
their own actions truth be told most
critics bring nothing to the table they
simply project their own insecurities
and add zero value to the conversation
and if we listen to them their toxicity
permeates our thoughts making it
difficult to create anything worthwhile
so you have two choices either create
and be criticized or hide from
meaningful work because you're scared of
a little bird poop personally I'd rather
cover my head and craft something worth
criticizing and Ryan I think that's
that's really what we're doing now is we
we really open ourselves up to the world
we have affect by having an audience in
front of us well when we first started
and had 52 people show them to the blog
or now where it's approaching 5 million
people and the podcast is approaching a
million people we have a sign here that
says criticize me and I think the thing
is we want to delineate between good
criticism and bad criticism here but I I
don't know about you but for me I tend
to lean on people that I care about in
whose opinions I trust and it's why I'll
call and I'll ask you what do you think
about this or with Sean if I'm writing
hey hey
Shawn can you tell me about about this
sentence or do you think do you think
this story really strikes a chord and
what would you change about this because
these are opinions that I appreciate and
then also when we are publishing a book
we'll go out to a whole bunch of alpha
readers and the beta readers and ask for
people who are willing to give us
criticism up front but do so in a in a
meaningful helpful articulate way as
opposed to people who just become
seagulls and fly over and and [ __ ] on so
what's the last whether it was in
regards to the minimalists or your
personal life what's the last good
criticism you got I think I get it from
from you all the time but wait a minute
I criticized you puppets well no I think
so but but I ask for it from you and I
think I think that's that's what's
different we you and I talk about stuff
all the time and I think criticism can
be as easy as I would do it this way but
here's why and that's why it's good it's
not it's the opposite of what bad
criticism is bad criticism is I don't
like that that is stupid
you are wrong I'm so disappointed in
your opinion okay but that doesn't tell
me why it's bad and and it's not helpful
so good criticism usually it's helpful
and and that comes from when someone's
intentions are good and they're not just
lashing out they're not having this this
fake outrage and and so that's actually
a pretty good segue here but the thing I
really wanted to read today is one of
the things that that we have we have
this internet culture now that we've set
up that has has a mimicked outrage for
no reason and it was amazing to me to
see people on on Twitter and social
media and other places that who are
outraged by the idea that no there's no
such thing as good debt people will like
legitimately got outraged by it and so I
want to read one more quick excerpt from
from our book essential and this one is
about fake outrage
there are times when outrage is an
appropriate reaction to current events
the twin towers cheating spouses and
violent crimes all in justices all valid
reasons for momentary rage most of the
time however our outrage is unwarranted
we shouldn't be offended but we are this
is especially true when the context of
with within the context of today's
internet culture social media has become
a breeding ground for armchair criticism
faux discontent and passive-aggressive
quote disappointment a place in which we
attempt to paradoxically decree our
tallest building by ridiculing every
nearby structure let's break that down
real quick Ryan so so I think that's
that's one of the big symptoms here man
is people in order to to not feel small
we as people want to criticize other
people yeah it's it's the old adage of
yeah and there's two ways to have a
tallest building in town and one is to
obviously tear everyone else's building
down that doesn't give you a taller
building no it just means you're
comparing yourself to everyone else as
opposed to going out and building a
taller building and it's amazing to me
that why people would want to follow
what we do and yet criticize it it
without without necessarily trying to
help I mean I don't understand it's
because we're challenging their beliefs
right it's a thing or their values yeah
yeah anytime you're challenging
someone's values and beliefs I mean
they're gonna have I know I have a
visceral reaction every time my beliefs
or values get challenged isn't that
interesting though because well maybe
we're not I don't think we're we're not
personally going out trying to jeno
individual's beliefs but what you're
saying is there the idea that's been
sparked they're now challenging their
own beliefs mm-hmm and that's a good
thing though right because for me I will
listen to I mean this is a really really
good example here when I listen to
podcast I will try to listen to like
Bill Maher who is very far left and then
Glenn Beck who's very far right in in
the same sitting so to speak or same
walking session because I don't
necessarily agree with either of their
opinions a hundred percent
but it challenges my beliefs and you
know what it helps me strengthen the
ones I believe in or the ones that are
weak it helps me reformulate them or
completely changed all together I would
dare to say and this is pure speculation
right but I would dare to say that
anyone who reacts viscerally like that
towards towards anything we talk about
whether it's debt or whether it's the
stuff or whether it's collections or
whatever it may be I would dare to say
that they do not have that approach with
life they don't have that approach of
okay I'm going to look at all sides I'm
gonna consider all sides and I'm going
to see how I feel I am gonna challenge
my beliefs I mean I know when I was
being raised Jehovah's Witness you know
those those beliefs that I had I just
remember literally literally like making
up excuses in my mind to like to justify
those beliefs and whether it was um I
remember the first time I'd like did
this I was young and I asked my dad I
was like dad I don't understand what
isn't the Bible will talk about
dinosaurs because like I loved dinosaurs
yeah he's like well you know the Bible
just talked about monsters of the sea
and you know but but you know my my my
guess is is that you know Jehovah put
those on on the earth to to break up the
earth to help break up the earth nowhere
in the bible does it say that but as you
know like oh yeah that makes sense
put dinosaurs on the earth to break up
the earth so like I would use and I
continued to use that that anecdotal
doesn't even anecdotal it's made up it's
it's it's a it's it's you know I used
that excuse to to to you know really
seed and root my beliefs and and a lot
of other little things like that and you
know looking back was that was that but
was that grasping like it was I need any
answer to fill this I don't think it was
grasping as much as I felt like I had it
you know figured out 98% of the way and
like there was 2% of the way that like I
had to
kind of make up these little things for
it isn't that funny how as we get older
I just turned 35 and and as as we get
older you know we another adage you know
other truism is you know the the the
more I learned the less I know and and I
feel that way and I think it what's
interesting is I know that I don't have
all the answers now in fact it's it's
funny I remember growing up my mom used
to always tell me yeah you'll you'll I
would ask her something I just don't
understand this I don't understand that
and it was some of them as complex or
emotional or spiritual or whatever and
she goes just wait until you're 35
you'll understand when you're 35 and I
first that pissed me off because I'm way
out but I won't understand now explain
it to me and I think what she was saying
is you need to get enough life
experience and by 35 what you'll
understand is that you'll never
understand it all and you'll never have
all the answers and that's the nice
thing and we don't we don't pretend that
we we have all the answers we have we
have some very good answers to some
things that have worked well for us but
generally that's through first failing
at least once sometimes more than once
and being able to learn from from that
that car crash and walk away from it and
in some cases literally from a car crash
like when and yeah 2014 when you almost
died in that car crash
I mean learning from from these crashes
and then course correcting thereafter
and so much of what I've learned is is a
course correction and in my own life and
that's really what we hope to to share
here and so I'm totally fine with people
criticizing it if it makes sense and if
it adds value but I'm even willing to
change my perspective I think some
criticism is good but getting back to
those seagulls and the in those trolls
it's just it's not productive and at
first it can't hurt your feelings but I
the other thing that's nice about it is
over time you know Ryan and I have been
doing this for almost six years now and
yes it's just like when you first start
working out like with heavy weights and
you start getting those calluses and man
your fingers hurt when you first start
playing guitar
your tips your fingers are bleeding
after a while and and you realize that
okay I need to build up these calluses
and I think over time enough criticism
allows you to build up those calluses it
doesn't make it not hurt it makes it
hurt less well it helps me - it helps me
to like really see the criticism for
what it is because you know if someone
walked into a room right now and was
like hey Ryan you're fat like there
would be a piece of me that would be
like oh man this is like these shorts
make my butt look big or less black
t-shirt not flatter is this black
t-shirt and like in those things would
go through my head but but then I would
also take a moment and be like wait a
minute
who is this person that's calling me fat
mm-hmm and why would they just come in
here and say that at the end of the day
like I can look at that and be like oh
okay well that's not someone I want to
be friends with right that's someone who
probably has her own bit of insecurity
and they're trying to project something
on me so so building up those calluses
like you said it's not it's not that it
makes it hurt less as much as I can look
at criticisms criticism now and say oh
wow that person is just having a
visceral reaction right I'm sorry that
they're having a bad day or that I have
hit a chord with them that has really
given them this reaction but there is
nothing valuable in the words that they
are saying to me but it you know the
obverse of that is sometimes people do
say stuff and I look at I'm like oh [ __ ]
like they actually have a point like you
know I asked you about the you know the
the most useful criticism you've had
recently that you can remember I
remember when we we had on over the
weekend we had set up a post it was like
right after the Orlando stuff mm-hmm and
it was like it was set up before they
were the Orlando stuff happened oh yeah
and it's this is on Facebook yeah it was
on Facebook and it and it said it was
something like you know cause like you
know we we put quotes on Facebook and
stuff our readers know that and it was
the quote most emergencies aren't
yeah really shitty timing yeah but it
was it was scheduled olds put that in
context so there's one person who helps
with some of our social media stuff her
name is Jessica Lynn Williams she's over
at the mind Palace podcast you've
actually heard her do a a guest cast on
here with her friend Melissa as well but
she helps out with she's on our team she
helps to post some social media stuff so
Ryan and I interact a lot with people on
social media but what she does is she
finds interesting articles to post on
our Facebook and Twitter and just so
that you we can share other simple
living tips with you but then she also
goes and so we have hundreds of essays
at the minimalists calm and and also we
have three books about intentional
living so she goes and pulls individual
quotes once a month from those books in
those essays and our our our words and
puts them on to our social media feeds
to be inspiration for other people and
social schedule month month in events
and so right after the the Orlando
shooting the terrorist attack she she
already had this thing scheduled it was
like the day of or the day after of that
Saturday actually and it said you know
most emergencies aren't and it was
pulled from this essay that we wrote
that in context it made a lot of sense
of most emergencies aren't and it's
still very true so it still holds true
the vast majority but you're right it
was totally a bad time it was bad timing
and someone on social media was like
what the hell are you doing oh yeah like
that's really inappropriate right now
right with the happenings and that that
made sense to me like that type of
criticism I was like oh well like I
didn't realize that this is what we had
scheduled right and none of us did
because you can't plan for every tragedy
right right in fact you know we've
written about that the other the other
thing I've got a ton of criticism for
was an essay right after the Paris
attacks but I think I think it's apropos
for just about every tragedy that we
have and it was called it was called
after the tragedy and let me see if I
can pull that up real quick but but but
I mean to your point though it's it's
it's not an issue when someone has a
legitimate concern like if I can look at
some criticism even if I mean
that particular criticism that I'm
talking about about that when we posted
that quote most emergencies aren't they
didn't have any like there was no cuss
words there was no there was no one
being like super oh that there were some
people I had to block oh yeah well let's
talk about that real quick I didn't see
so I we we both do this all the time but
I'm tend to be a bit more liberal with
it than others just because if you just
want to be a troll and especially you
have an egg avatar and you're showing up
and saying stupid stuff or you're
cussing at me and I've gotten death
threats on social media before and it
was especially after this parish tragedy
thing and so yeah I don't mess around
with that but if someone is just is
being obscene or rude I'm gonna block
you decide okay because that is not
helpful right and so the question that I
ask is the one I got from from Dan
Harris and I asked us all the time now
is this useful yeah and if I can if I
can say no that I need to move on from
it yeah I even the even the obscene
comments I can look through the
obscenities and like literally like I
will cut out all the obscenities and
look at the the actual comment and I'll
still look at that and be like this is
useful or it's not useful 99.999% of the
time the obscenities the comments with
the obscenities are not useful criticism
but there are some times where it's like
wow that could have been said a lot
nicer but yeah I see where they're
coming from
you could have curse words and it sure
but to me curse words when used well are
not obscene and I think that that is the
perfect example here so after Paris but
you could post this after the Orlando
attacks let's talk about this because
this is a perfect setup for criticism
actually so this was last year during
the the whole Paris thing which was
awful but the the essay is called after
the tragedy we'll put it Shawn if you
can put it in the show notes as well
yesterday the morning after the horrific
terrorist attacks in Paris I posted the
following quote on my personal Instagram
account in light of the Paris tragedy
I'm reminded of Anthony Jeselnik
uncomfortable but honest commentary on
internet quote sadness to paraphrase
Jeselnik
when something horrible happens
everybody runs to social media and
writes the exact same thing my thoughts
and prayers are with the victims do you
know what that's worth [ __ ] nothing
less than nothing you aren't giving any
of your time your money or even your
compassion all you're saying is don't
forget about me today
ergo let's do something more than post a
stock photo of a peace sign on social
media let's find ways to contribute
beyond ourselves and of course the this
is continuing the essay here the
positive comments on this post were
numerous but there were also a
spattering of fake outrage as well as
some crude personal attacks and even one
potential death threat which I deleted
some people missed the point entirely
that they seem to take my post as a
personal assault as if I was judging
them for their social media postings but
of course I wasn't because I know better
I understand that the judgement is but a
mere reflecting the insecurities of the
person who's doing the judging besides I
don't give a damn about internet trolls
hurt feelings I'm concerned about the
well-being of the victims and so rather
than judge the comment thread Crusaders
I wanted to emphasize that we must do
more than exercise our Twitter fingers a
hashtag and a photo alone will not solve
the problem and they can be dangerous
because they ape the form of real action
if you want to effectively contribute
after the tragedy here are a few options
number one money if you can afford it
donate to charities that are helping the
victims even a couple bucks makes a
difference
number two resources our most precious
resource resources are our time and our
attention our influence and our
creativity all of which when done well
can prove even more beneficial than
charitable donations here's an idea
find a handful of friends co-workers or
members of your community and have a
discussion about how you might use these
resources to collectively contribute not
only only for this strategy tragedy but
for the everyday world around you you'll
be amazed by how much is
group of compassionate people can
uncover then whatever you decide work
together to take action and here's the
point here ultimately caring is a verb
real love and support and understanding
means we are concerned enough to express
it through our actions sure so sure
social media can be a good first step as
long as it's just that a first step once
we've expressed our grief and shown our
solidarity we must then do something
about it because if we don't then all
we're left with are well-meaning but
solipsistic status updates and that's
what I want to avoid Ryan and and and so
and of course people took offense to the
thing that cleared up the offense here
as well and and but the good news is it
also encouraged people to take action
and so we've got tons of photos from
people were like you're right let's do
this let me get involved in my community
yeah I live in Kalamazoo but I can still
do something and in fact Ryan so you and
I were in Missoula Montana right now but
the coffee shop that we started earlier
this year in st. Petersburg Florida we
did an event there this past week
weekend for the Pride Parade and we
donated 100% of the proceeds to the
victims fund 100% of the profits rather
to the victims fund there and in the
next month Ryan and I are flying down to
Orlando with Shaun and we're gonna do a
charity event in Orlando with our film
minimalism the documentary and and a
hundred percent of those proceeds as
well including the proceeds from our
distributor they're donating to all of
the victims from from this Orlando
shooting so it's good to start talking
about this stuff on the internet on
social media as long as that's a good
spark to actually do something about it
and so it's not just me and you who are
doing something it allows other people
to contribute to these victims funds as
well and even if you don't have the
money you have all the other resources I
just mentioned you can get involved with
your community you can use your
creativity what gifts do you have that
you can contribute back you can help the
victims of these things as opposed to
starting you can start with social media
but let's let's go beyond that and this
isn't me criticizing an
it's saying here's what I noticed in
myself and I need to be willing to move
beyond my keyboard and actually do
something good for the world right yeah
and you know we're not like this is not
an episode to defend ourselves by the
way like we're you know we're not
bringing up all the criticism and just
so we can sit here and say like oh all
your criticism means nothing I mean
ultimately what I would like our
listeners they get from this is don't be
scared of criticism like go out if you
if you have something subversive that
you want to talk about then talk about
it if you feel really really strongly I
think the only time you shouldn't is if
you're if you're not being genuine or
you know if it doesn't align with your
values and beliefs but even for the
folks out there who are trying to
integrate minimalism into their lives
and you're gonna get some criticism for
it but again it put yourself out there I
mean if you are following the status quo
and worrying about what other people
think about you and and really letting
that control your life well then you're
not really living your life you're
living a life that other people want you
to live so that really reminds me of
Seth Godin when heat so Seth Godin he's
my favorite blogger for sure he remember
that conference we were at Tara she she
attended one of that's programs but she
got up and she was young maybe 19 20
years old I was at misfit oh yeah she's
she made a sign that said Seth Godin is
my Beyonce and I just loved that because
Seth Godin I think is also my Beyonce
blogging but he he talks about criticism
and what you're saying I agree that is
the takeaway here and so here's what he
wrote not too long ago actually it was a
while ago on criticism why haven't you
launched the thing that you'd like to
launch fear not just the fear of failure
fear of failure is actually overrated as
an excuse why because if you work for
someone then more often than not the
actual cost of failure is absorbed by
the organization not you
if your product launch fails they're not
going to fire you the company will make
a bit less money and then move on what
people are afraid of isn't failure its
blame criticism we don't choose to be
remarkable because we're worried about
criticism we hesitate to create
innovative movies launch new human
resource and initiatives design a menu
that makes diners take notice or give an
audacious sermon because we're worried
deep down that someone will hate it will
hate it and call us on it that's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard what a
waste of money who's responsible for
this sometimes the criticism doesn't
even have to be that obvious the fear of
quote I'm surprised you launched this
without doing more research is enough to
get many people to do a lot more
research to study something to death and
then kill it hey at least you didn't get
criticized fear of criticism is a
powerful deterrent because the criticism
doesn't actually have to occur for the
fear to set in ooh
that's that's deep man so the criticism
doesn't have to occur you don't even
have to get criticized you just have to
have the fear of being criticized to not
do something meaningful watch a few
people get criticized for being
innovative and it's pretty easy to
persuade yourself that the very same
thing will happen to you if you're not
careful
constructive criticism of course is a
terrific tool and that's really the
point I want to get to here if a critic
tells you a quote I don't like it or
this is disappointing he's done no good
at all in fact quite the opposite is
true he used his power to injure without
giving you any information to help you
do better next time
worse he hasn't given those listening
any data to make a thoughtful decision
on their own not only that but by
refusing to reveal the basis for his
criticism he's being a coward because
there's no way to challenge his opinion
I admit it
when I get a bad review my feelings are
hurt after all it would be nice if a
critic said the title of mine was a
breakthrough an inspirational thoughtful
book that
Planes how everything from politics to
wine is marketed through stories but
sometimes they don't which is just about
enough to ruin your day but this time it
didn't it didn't because I realized what
a badge of honor it is to get a bit of
shallow criticism it means that I
confounded expectations that I didn't
deliver the sequel or the simple
practical guide that some expected it
means that in fact I did something worth
remarking on I think that that's the
point Ryan I'm not gonna read the rest
of this essay but if you want to do
something remarkable something worth
remarking on and sometimes some of those
remarks are going to be criticism I'm
always saying our books aren't I haven't
made it until we get those one-star
reviews now I don't want a bunch of
one-star reviews that are that are
inarticulate that aren't gonna help me
out or whatever but the point is that
you're gonna get those because people
are going to remark and the alternative
is for us to do something that is
unremarkable you your average person who
works for the IRS unless they're doing
something that is changing the way that
taxes are collected or something if
you're just filling out forms and and
checking the boxes you are literally
doing something that is unremarkable and
you might get your peer review once a
year or whatever or your bosses review
but it's not it's not something that is
going to be remarked on by others and
it's not having an effect it's not
influencing other people to make changes
that that they can make wasn't there a
New York Times or something where they
did it they did a test and essentially
they found out that people were more
scared of being criticized or
embarrassed than they were of death yes
that stems from the the studies of
public speaking and the number one fear
of public speaking is of course
criticism but it's immediate criticism
that's why it's so drastic right because
you and I can get in front of a crowd
now after doing it hundreds of times but
I remember when I first started doing
public speaking it was for our stores so
Ryan and I used to work in the retail
world and when I was maybe 20
- I was managing two retail stores at
the time and Ryan you worked at one of
those stores and the rice - at the begin
of the month I get up get up and I'd
give a promo pack discussion right I'd
get both stores together and and get up
in front of the you know dozen or so
employees there were two small stores
and and I was terrified to speak in
front of a dozen people who I knew
really well and and I was at one
half-hour a month it's been so much time
prepping and I was still just stammering
and and barely getting through the talk
and constantly reading for my notes but
over time you do that enough and you
build up that muscle and and yes you can
start small like that you don't have to
get if you don't have to speak in front
of 3,000 people and you you and I can do
that now and it's not like we don't get
butterflies beforehand we still
certainly get butterflies or at least I
know I do it's not the same it's not the
same feeling of terror
it's a feeling of excitement right and
I'm able to understand that now
physiologically they're pretty similar
symptoms yeah terror and excitement but
I'm able to sort of manifest that as as
excitement after doing this and knowing
what to expect because the worst thing
that could happen is actually not that
bad you're the worst thing that could
happen in front of 3,000 people you know
you and I could get up there and and
just start telling lame you know Rodney
Dangerfield jokes and actually his jokes
are pretty fun take my wife please I
need I need two women right that way
that way when I fall asleep there
someone to talk to bunch of lame jokes
like that yeah and and it would go
horribly because we're not Ronnie
dangerous but the worst thing could
happen is that you know people wouldn't
like it and and that I would the worst
thing would happen is I'll be wasting
their time which would be unfortunate I
don't want to do that I would care more
about wasting their time than the
criticism I would get right and really
the criticism for would be deserved that
the main criticism waste of my time and
I think that's really the point here is
as we're getting criticized it allows us
to build up those calluses to allow us
to do things that are actually
more remarkable because the opposite is
not is a life where you're not alive at
all and so it's accepting and in many
ways appreciating the criticism for what
it is even the shitty criticism where
it's you know what I didn't like this
this sucked I was disappointed which is
actually let me get back to this so so
before we close out here I want to
finish that fake outrage essay here
because it talks about about that and so
we here we here we sit glued to our
keyboards and glowing terminals stewing
in a disturbing mixture of anger and
schadenfreude as we scroll through the
endless stream waiting for the next
politically incorrect gaffe to ignite
our flame of faking the indignation
rarely is a meaningful discussion even
attempted just take one look at the
comments at any popular YouTube video
that I mean that's that that's your
prime example there you go to youtube
video I get me our TED talk as close to
a couple million views I there's no way
I'm gonna go look at those no I didn't I
did the other day it was just yeah I
don't wanna hear but here's the thing
that is a sea of trolls that is
unproductive and so seek out the
productive ones but also appreciate the
other ones that are there because it
means what you're doing is being worked
upon with in recent years the outrage
has amped up considerably making room
for endless commentary on banal pop
culture happenings the pit the perils of
deflategate a formal olympians new
pronoun anthony Weiner's weiner not to
mention a dozen new presidential
candidates who have entered a race in
which the main qualification seems to be
outrage for whatever is said by their
opponents all of which have incited
tantrums from both sides of each quote
issue but who gives a damn well sadly
the answers seem to be everybody gives a
damn because everyone has the tools to
be an amateur critic now there are
scores of trolls waiting to disgorge
their opposing viewpoint even your
authors hear the minimalists aren't
immune to the wrath
of the fuming masses a topic as
seemingly innocuous as minimalism or in
this case innocuous as debt I mean you
can't get more innocuous than that I
don't think as minimalism or debt
somehow infuriates hundreds if not
thousands of noisy keyboard mercenaries
without good reason the self-righteous
are offended by that which doesn't
really affect them and because they've
decided that someone else's lifestyle is
somehow an affront to their own that's
exactly what you're talking about a
moment ago Ryan
they reflexively spout their gibberish
in an attempt to justify a viewpoint
that nobody asked them to justify in the
first place we've all done this at some
point and that's really why I wanted to
talk about this day right we're all
critics we're all responsible for this
so when I criticize now I want to make
sure it's constructive and so well
that's a leaving a review on Yelp or on
Google or if it's giving feedback to
someone even if it's a one-star review
it needs to be constructive and if it's
five-star review if I had an amazing
experience I'm gonna go out of my way
not to just say hey that was great
because that's not constructive either
tell them why it's great why did it
resonate with me and that's really
important for me to do so we've all done
this at some point we've all gotten
offended without asking ourselves why
and then used our fake outrage to cache
judgment upon others we do this we judge
people because it helps us feel better
and pretending to be offended as much
easier than attempting to breach the
walls of introspection hmm Manson
doesn't read something like this I go
back to somebody I need to take my own
advice sometimes like let's just breach
the walls of introspection instead of
instead of reacting on on impulse but
this good feeling is fleeting of course
and so we judge more and more in an
attempt to give grounds for our initial
judgment all the while increasing our
dosage of outrage it's an ugly downward
spiral and from a spectators distance
standing far from the backlog of
comments and posts and at replies the
enraged look like fools because when we
step away and observe we soon realize
that this kind of judgment
says more about the judge than the
judged after all judgment is just a
mirror reflecting the insecurities of
the person who's doing the judging true
we all judge but it is best to do so
with reason respect and empathy rather
than rage resentment and disdain that
have fused our everyday lives but the
truth is that for the vast majority of
us most outrage inducing events RRL are
irrelevant and thus outrage itself is a
waste of time few people are affected by
deflated footballs or transgender
celebrities and yet we act as if these
events directly shape our lives we judge
we throw in our unsolicited two cents
and then feel a particular kind of
emptiness when the dust clears and all
that remains is a heap of hurt feelings
allowing others to offend is natural
it's a default setting but it is also
unnecessary an offended man or woman is
a defenseless man or woman hmm
but it also but it doesn't have to be
this way at least not on an individual
level we can choose not to be offended
hmm so stop it let it go
change the channel turn it off
unsubscribe unfriend unfollow mute block
walk away breathe outrage is a fool's
errand and unless you're a fool you
needn't carry the weight of another
person's burdens let the fools do their
own heavy lifting perhaps what we need
is a reduced dose of outrage and a
higher dosage of a letting go you see
letting go of outrage is not the same as
embark is embrace as embracing apathy
outrage and apathy are obverse signs of
the same sides of the same coin by
refusing to be offended by life's
minutiae we refuse to step into outrages
blast radius and thus will be refused to
cast judgment arbitrarily ultimately
avoiding the outrage is how we can
approach controversial and interesting
topics with honest worthwhile
discussions
even when an occasion warrants outrage
such as murder or racism or Game six of
the 1998 NBA Finals great game no was
not a great game ruined my life
what we do with our with our ire is a
different story just because our
emotions are justified that doesn't mean
we're required to acquiesce rarely does
acting out of rage justified or not lead
to a desirable outcome besides the only
person who has the right to worry about
deflating Tom Brady's balls is Janelle
bündchen and if that joke offends you
then please go back to the top and read
this essay again that's crazy well Ryan
I know we were in a conference room
right now we need to give this up in a
minute
any last words on criticism you want to
talk about um yeah I would just say for
anyone listening keep you know if you
want to criticize this keep it coming
just try to make it useful well not not
so visceral and if you know our whole
goal here is to add value to everyone's
lives it is it is not to listen to
ourselves pontificate it's not so we can
feel like we're some kind of you know
minimalist gurus this is this is
literally for you to help you if it's
not helping you then turn us off you
have the option of doing that yeah and I
would encourage you to turn off anything
that is not broadening your your horizon
isn't isn't helping you either change
your beliefs or strengthen your beliefs
as well so so whether that's us or blogs
you fall our podcast you follow or or
whatever else it it may be movies you
watch however you spend your time it
should help you grow and ideally
hopefully we're helping you grow I think
the cool thing is you don't have to
agree with us 100% of the time either
we don't even agree with us 100% of the
time and Ryan and I even we agree we
tend to approach an agreement from a
different side of it and and we help
each other get there and so so
encouraged I encourage you to help
yourself get there as well by by
listening by reading by doing the work
and doing the introspection necessary
and part of that will actually be list
to criticism and then doing something
worth criticizing you know it's crazy
man I feel so strongly about what what
we do like I have never I just have
never lived a life that has been so much
in alignment with my values and beliefs
like I feel so good about what we do
if literally it was the obverse where we
got 99% this rule crappy feedback and
just that one person was like dude you
changed my life yeah like thank you so
much for your perspective it really
helped me with my perspective [ __ ] it
would be worth it for me yeah yeah you
know it's well thankfully it's not that
right now but yeah I'm not saying I want
it to be that way right and I think
that's other thing too we don't we don't
do things to just try to get people
outraged on purpose you know we're not
out here being your shock jocks or
whatever we genuine genuine ly want to
add value to other people's lives and
whether that's helping them with their
clutter or their their financial clutter
which is debt or anything else we just
we just want to provide you with that
recipe take some ingredients out of it
and go from there before we close out
we've got a couple things we're gonna be
in in Fargo North Dakota on July 19th
and then we're going to be in Orlando we
have a special charity event down there
on August I think it's the 11th you can
find both of those dates on our tour
page over at the minimalists com a slash
tour and of course our documentary comes
out on August 2nd finally whoo yeah it's
in theaters in Canada and Australia
right now but then the the documentary
comes out August 2nd it's going to be on
a whole bunch of different platforms you
can pre-order it right now though if you
just go to minimalism film.com you can
get all the details for that if you
preorder it over there on Vimeo you
actually get six hours of bonus
interviews and content as well and Shawn
if you can throw in maybe some we'll put
some voicemails in here some tips and
tricks from from some of our listeners
we'll add them in here right now
hi guys my name's Amanda from Revelstoke
Canada and I have a suggestion regarding
how to get out of student debt because I
was able to get out of over thirty-five
thousand dollars in student debt in
a year and I wanted to share how I did
it so it's kind of a crazy idea
basically I did it by working through
University and also afterwards for a few
years by getting paid to travel the
world and specifically what I did was
work on cruise ship and during
university I worked as youth activity
staff during every university break
possible so all summer all Christmas
break all spring break so that's what I
did all throughout my university years
and then the year after I got out of uni
when I had the $35,000 worth of student
loans when I finish my program I
actually went on board full-time I got
promoted to an onboard crew training
position and in that first year of
full-time employment I was able to pay
off my full $35,000 it's too long so
that was just really really cool so not
only did I get to do it you know worked
my way through and helped pay for my
university while I was working on board
I was able to pay off any remaining debt
exists right after and I did that for
another after my first full time year I
did cruise ships for another three or
four years so 10 years in total and yeah
so some other examples might be outside
of cruise ships might be teaching
English in Asia or working at resource
during any breaks or even after
university as well but finding a way to
work a cool job get paid to travel
perhaps but finding a job that's going
to pay for accommodation groceries
flight so that all the money that you're
making you're actually saving and able
to be putting towards your debt so I
hope this little tip helps people and
thanks so much for all you do hi guys my
name is Rachel I'm from Lisle Illinois
and I'm in a long time listener have you
guys ever since your podcast started I
think I've listened to all your episodes
maybe I missing a couple um but I was
just listening to the one about travel
and but the question again came up you
know does this add value into my life
and 10i afford this and I just had a
thought about the question can I afford
this but I kind of wanted to add into
the mix so so he does have talked about
you know can I afford this monetarily
can I afford to take up
bass in my in my life or in my house and
I was also thinking can I afford the
anxiety you are like the feeling of
guilt that might come along with
purchasing something or spending money
on something that somewhere inside me I
know doesn't really align with my values
and I thought of this Esther the the
other person who called in about their
compulsive travel costs and so maybe a
question that he could ask himself he
knows he loves traveled and itself not a
bad thing but he could ask himself can I
afford how I feel like that twinge of
you know not being happy with myself
that kind of goes into the mix of how
much he enjoys travel because he can
wait and and save up the money or you
know make more informed decisions about
which Tipsy wants to go on then they'll
be like 100 percent enjoyable instead of
having some percentage of of having that
little twinge of guilt or anxiety or
that kind of negative feeling associated
with with putting himself into death hi
my name is shisha
and I am from the sandwiches girl Bay
Area and I just saw a comment regarding
consumerism and really just purchasing
things changing your mindset when it
comes to items and consumerism I know
once I had kind of made the shift when
it comes to wanting to go out and buy
things I had also struggled with the the
second part of that is once I did buy
something I needed I kind of felt that
heart racing you know satisfaction even
though I'd worked on one part of keeping
myself from wanting all these things to
go and buy once I went and bought things
I actually needed I couldn't really
control that feeling of yeah yeah
thought this and you go through at the
second I needed I needed I'm so excited
and I thought it wasn't a healthy
feeling to have this rush of adrenaline
just because I bought something so
something that I've been doing recently
to try to combat that and to work
through that is
when I buy something that I say I need I
will not let myself pull it out of the
bag for a certain amount of time so for
example I just bought a new dress a
black dress and I bought it
intentionally because it's good quality
and I knew that it would be very diverse
and I could use it for a lot of
different things and I was so excited
about this black dress and I got this
adrenaline rush that I felt good because
I knew that it was something I actually
needed but it was also an unhealthy
excitement so I kept it in the bag for a
week and I didn't let myself pull it out
because I needed to give myself time to
recognize that this is not bringing me
true satisfaction this isn't bringing me
true adrenaline and excitement yes I
bought it and I have it and I wanted to
be able to get to that place where ok I
satisfied the need but I also am not
letting it be the full satisfaction
toward want is that make sense and so
I'm not just one little tip that I've
been using to kind of combat those
unhealthy - you know systems that we've
created in our brain to want and need
and consume so yeah the tail-end even
working on that rather than just out
front and fighting all these things that
you want to need before you go and buy
them but also that tail end of one side
by this not letting it become this
overwhelming adrenaline rush all right
Joe that's it for this episode if you
leave here with one message of course we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening we'll see you next
time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without
every little feeling that you got a hand
every little thing that you got hey you
gotta reach for you got a grin oh I bet
that you'll be fine without me
you